[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم صعدت الحكومه العراقيه من وتيره
العمليه العسكريه في الانبار وتمثل هذا
التصعيد في قصف غير مسبوق على الفلوجه وسط
اتهامات باستخدام البراميل المتفجره تزامن
ذلك مع تصريحات امريكيه عن تدريب قوات
خاصه عراقيه في اطار الحرب الحكوميه ضد
تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه في العراق والشام
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقش في محورين
دلالات تصعيد الحكومه العراقيه في الانبار
وتوقيته وماذا يمثل الدعم الامريكي لحكومه
المالك في ضوء العمليه العسكريه الجاريه
في
[موسيقى]
الانبار قصف غير مسبوق على الفلوجه هكذا
وصف اهال المدينه القصف الذي تعرضت له
الفلوجه في الساعات الماضيه متهمين القوات
الحكوميه بالقاء براميل متفجره على مناطق
عده في المدينه هذا التصعيد من جانب
القوات الحكوميه تزامن مع تصريحات لمسؤول
امريكي حول نيه بلاده تدريب قوات خاصه
عراقيه في الاردن اوائل الشهر المقبل في
اطار الحرب الامريكيه ضد تنظيم الدوله
الاسلاميه يمضي المالك في خياره الامني
الانبار تتحول لديه الى حقل لاختبار القوه
هذه المره يقصف وبعنف الفلوجه وبحسب اهال
فان ثمه رغبه في الانتقام تحرك الرجل ما
يفسر برايهم عشوائيه القصف والاهم نوعيه
السلاح المستخدم ففي رواياتهم ان الجيش
لجا الى استنساخ تجربه نظيره السوري
فاستخدم البراميل المتفجره في قصفه احدى
المدارس الثانويه وان تقصف مدرسه على هول
الامر وفقا لاي منظمه حقوقيه قد تنظر فيه
فذلك لان القصف فيما يؤكد الاهالي لا يميز
بين منطقه واخرى لكن الروايه الحكوميه
تشدد على ان المستهدف ليس السكان بل مسلحي
دوله الاسلام في العراق والشام فالحرب اذا
ليست ضد عشائر الانبار ولا سكانها بل ضد
من يتخذونه دروعا بشريه وعليه يدرجون
العمليه الاخيره في سياق عريض بدا في
نهايه ديسمبر الماضي ويشمل منطقه شاسعه
المساحه على الحدود العراقيه مع سوريا
والعراق للقضاء على ما يسميه المالك
الارهاب هدف يقول منتقده انه يسعى من
خلاله لتصدير ما يحدث في الانبار على غير
حقيقته وهي بالنسبه لهم مظالم تصل الى ما
يصفونه بالتطهير للمكون السني في
اما الالحاح عليه فيضمن له كما يقولون
تعاطف الولايات المتحده ما يفسر برايهم
اعلان واشنطن اخيرا انها ستانفورد تدريب
قوات عراقيه لمكافحه الارهاب وبحسب مسؤول
في البنتاجون فان عددا صغيرا من القوات
الامريكيه الخاصه سيشارك في التدريب الذي
يبدا في اوائل الشهر المقبل ولافت هنا ان
يؤكد المسؤول ان تنظيم الوله الاسلام في
العراق والشام عدو لواشنطن كما في بغداد
ياتي هذا بعيد انتخابات تشريعيه اعلى
خلالها المالك من شان الملف الامني على
سواه سعيا لكسب تاييد الناخب العراقي
واستدرار التعاطف الدولي له باعتبار ان اي
بديل اخر هو فوضا امنيه تعصف بالاقليم كله
للعراق
وحسب موضوع حلقتنا هذا نناقشه مع الاستاذ
جاسم الموسوي من بغداد عضو اللجنه
الاعلاميه اتلاف دوله القانون وايضا من
الانبار الاستاذ همام حسين عضو مجلس ثوار
الانبار نرحب بضيفي من بغداد ومن الانبار
ابدا معك استاذ جاسم الموسوي في بغداد
لماذا هذا التصعيد الحكومي المتصاعد في
الانبار وفي هذا
التوقيت شكرا لحضرتك اخت خديجه والى قناه
الجزيره اخر ما يفكر به السيد المالكي انه
رجل انتقام اولا السيد المالكي كان حليما
وحكيما وتاخر باتخاذ القرار لحقيقه تطهير
الفلوجه وبالتالي كل ما يشاع امر متوقع ان
لان المالكي فاز وللمره الثالثه واكتسح
الاصوات ولا بد لهؤلاء ان يسوقوا او ان
ينقلوا ما حدث من دراما في سوريا الى
الواقع العراقي هذه البراميل التي يشار
اليها لاحظي حتى هذا البرميل الذي اثرتم
في تقريركم كتب عليه في القلم الماجك ما
الذي يجعلنا نكتب يا زهراء ويا علي اذا
كنا نريد ان نستهدف هذه التنظيمات
الارهابيه وانتم اشرتم ايضا في هذا
التقرير على ان العراق يواجه تنظيمات
الدوله الاسلاميه وهي تنظيمات ارهابيه انا
انق انقلها لك شخصيا معلش نريد ان نستوضح
عن الوضع في في الانبار طبعا بالنسبه
لنتائج الانتخابات لم تعلن بعد النتائج
رسميا في انتظار العنان عما تقول انه فوز
لنوري المالكي وبالتالي هناك من يحاول ان
ينتقم منه القصف على الفلوجه يقال ان
الحكومه العراقيه تستخدم فيه اسلحه اشد
فتكا من بينها البراميل المتفجره على غرار
ما يحدث في سوريا ما رايك يعني اولا لا صح
لا صح لما تناقلته بعض وسائل الاعلام من
اجل تشويه صوره الجيش العراقي وواجه
تنظيمات ارهابيه العراق لو اراد ان يستخدم
هذه البراميل لا يحتاج الى شرعيه سياسيه
واعلاميه لانه يذهب الى تطهير منطقه جزء
من هيبه الدوله ولكن العراق عازم وتحديدا
السيد المالكي كنا معه في اجتماع قلنا له
يجب ان تح احسم الوضع في الفلوجه قال لن
احسم على حساب المدنيين في الفلوجه انا
اعطيت اوامري للقوه الجويه لان تستهدف فقط
التنظيمات العسكريه ولاحظي ان كل ما يعرض
من قتلى هم تنظيمات ارهابيه يضعون الاحزمه
الناسفه وهم قتلى بمعنى ان الجيش العراقي
كان دقيقا في محاوله تطهير الفلوجه ويوم
امس الدكتور رافع العيسا وهو خصم للسيد
المالكي يقول ان الفلوجه هي تحت حراب
التنظيمات الارهابيه ما الذي نستطيع ان
نفعله ان نقدمه الفلو
من الانبار بالنسبه للانبار استاذ همام
حسين الوضع ميدانيا هل فعلا من يقتلون هم
مقاتلوا التنظيمات التي يسميها الان
الاستاذ جاسم الموسوي التنظيمات الارهابيه
اي مسلحي تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه في
العراق والشام هل الوضع هكذا فعلا على
الارض يعني اولا مرحبا بكم وقبل كل شيء
يعني معروف لكل المستمعين والمشاهدين
لقناتكم الموقره انه هنالك صراع ارادتين
على ارض العراق وبالذات بالتحديد وبخاصه
على ارض الانبار هنالك مشروع وطني للخلاص
من هكذا حكومه مرتبطه بالمشروع الصفوى
الصهيوني والمدعم من قبل امريكا وايران في
المنطقه والاجنه واضحه اصبحت عبر عشر
سنوات والغايات ايضا والاهداف واضحه
وبالمقابل هنالك
اراده وطنيه مقاومه لهذا المشروع فخلال
هذه الفتره منذ ان بدات المعركه في على
ساحه الانبار اتضحت الحقائق جليه انه
المالكي لا يريد استهداف المسلحين ولو كان
حقيقه راد ان يستهدف المسلحين كما ذكر له
حل الغادرين انه هناك كان عدد 36 مسلح من
تنظيمات بما يقال الدوله الاسلاميه او بما
يسمى داعش لكان من السهوله جدا القاء
القبض عليهم في ساحه الاعتصام ولكن تحول
الموضوع الى هدف اكبر من هذا انه هذه
المحافظه التي كانت عصيه على على على
الاحتلال الامريكي والان اصبحت هي معقل
للمقاومه المشروع الايراني في المنطقه
ولذلك يسعى المالكي بايعاز من اسياده في
ايران وامريكا الى تركيع اهالي الانبار
وبدا بدات الهستريا السياسيه والهستريا
العسكريه واضحه وجليه في سياسته العسكريه
به هذه المنطقه حيث بدا يستخدم سلاح
المدفعيه والطيران تؤكد تؤكد تؤكد استخدام
هذا النوع من
الاسلحه نعم موجود ولو كان هنالك مت ر
لدخول وسائل الاعلام الى هذه المناطق
لكانت الصور تنقل بحقائقها الدامغه ومن
خلال بعض القنوات المنصفه حقيقه بدات تنقل
كيف ان هذه الاسلحه المحرمه حقيقه دوليا
من من البراميل المتفجره والتي تحمل
الغازات التي سوف تظهر نتائجها العكسيه
والمدمره من الامراض السرطانيه كما فعل
اسياده في في
الفلوجه في بدايه المعارك الفلوجه الاولى
والفلو الثانيه فسيد التي العزيزه الموضوع
لا يحتاج الى ادله اصبحت الادله واضحه من
يريد ان يستهدف المسلحين فالمسلمين هم
يضربون الان الطوق الواضح والعصي على امام
قوات المالكي لكان المالك يتجرع ان يقدم
قواته والدخول الى الفلوجه من خلال مرحله
او مرحله زمنيه مضى عليها خمسه اشهر ولكن
هو عجز عن مواجهه المسلحين وصمودهم الازل
اسطوري فانتقل الى مرحله التدمير الشامل
لهذه المدينه والعقوبه الج الجماعيه حيث
اصبحت النتائج مدمره لهذه المحافظه ولهذه
المدينه بالذات هنالك نزوح لمئات والاف
للعوائل وهنالك اصابات خطيره وهنالك عدد
كبير من القتلى وصل الى اكثر من 300 شهيد
واكثر من
1300 جريح ومعاق فالموضوع سيدتي العزيزه
لا يحتاج هذه الارقام 300 قتيل و00 جريح
كما تقول سيد همام حسين والسؤال في الواقع
للاستاذ جاسم الموسوي كان هناك مساعي اذا
لتحقيق اتفاق بين الحكومه وبين العشائر
مصادر عشائريه قالت ان هذه المساعي فشلت
في التوصل الى اتفاق بين الحكومه والعشائر
بسبب رفض السيد نوري المالك الانسحاب من
الانبار ما
قولك يعني اول انا سوف لن اجيب حقيقه على
هذه التخرصات التي اعطت للشعب العراقي
الداعم للسيد المالكي على انه صفوي
وصهيوني وامريكي هؤلاء تجار الدم نعرفهم
ونعرف من اين يستلمون من قطر ومن السعوديه
اموالهم دعيني اقول لك السيد المالكي قدم
سته محاولات وهذه المحاولات تبنتها قوى
سنيه الدكتور صالح المطلق مهدي الصميدعي
كثير من علماء السنه ولكن المالكي لا يقدم
تنازلات على حساب شعب الانبار اهالي
الانبار لذلك هم ارادوا ان للاسف الشديد
ان يجعلوا من الارهاب ذراعا اخر لعقده
السلطه التي تعتاش في ذهنيه هؤلاء
الطائفيين لو كنا ناخذ الاوامر من ايران
لما انتظرنا الى هذه اللحظه لا نستهدف
الفلوجه والفلو جزء من العراق ن استذ
لماذا لا ينسحب الا كان هناك حديث نعم عن
اتفاق بين الحكوم نعم هنا على ان ايضا
العشائر تتعهد هي ايضا بتضييق الخناق على
مقاتلي الدوله الاسلاميه وتر نعم تفضل ست
خديجه انسحبنا سحبنا الجيش العراقي من
الانبار فسقطت الانبار بيد تجار الدم
هؤلاء وتنظيمات داعش ومحافظ الانبار خرج
على شاشات التلفاز يستنجد بالقوات
العراقيه لمن ن لماذا سعيتم اذا الى
الاتفاق مع استاذ جاسم لماذا اذا السعيد
للاتفاق معهم في هذه الحاله لا هؤلاء
هؤلاء هؤلاء لا يقبلون ولا يرغبون
وهم ليس لديهم اراده سياسيه وهؤلاء ياخذون
الاوامر من قطر ومن السعوديه ومن تركيا
واتحداهم الان انا اتحداهم اذا جلسوا الى
طاوله مفاوضات هؤلاء لا يريدون الحل
السلمي يريدون ان ياخذ ان يجعلوا الفلوجه
بوابه لاسقاط العمليه الديمقراطيه في
العراق ليس ناخذ رد همام حسين على هذا
الكلام استاذ همام حسين يقول الاستاذ جاسم
المساوي بانه عندما انسحبنا من الانبار
دخلها مسلح الدوله الاسلاميه في العراق
والشام وال الشام وهذه هي النتيجه كما
نراها على الارض ما قولك يعني اختي
الفاضله اولا كل كل العالم اطلع على
العمليه العسكريه التي جريت اجريت في
صحراء الانبار وكانت هكذا تنظيمات بما
يسمى الدوله الاسلاميه او مسمى اخر موجوده
في في في صحراء الانبار وجند وسخرها
للمالكي القوات العسكريه قوات الجيش
والاسلحه المرافقه لها الا انه بعد بين
يوم وضحاها اعلنت وزاره الدفاع انه انتهت
العمليات العسكريه بانتصار الباهر وكبير
على هذا هكذا ميليشيات على ما تسميه
الدوله او على ما يسمى بالدوله الاسلاميه
طيب لماذا لماذا اولا وكد اخت يعني عذرا
لمقاطعه اللوم يقع اولا على على قوه الجيش
لماذا الجيش الان يدخل المدن في كل مدن
العراق بغض النظر عن قضيه الانبار تدخل
قوات الجيش الى الى مدن الموصل
وديالا والمناطق البقيه لماذا الجيش لا
يضرب كما موجود في بقيه دول العالم حزاما
امنيا كبيرا جدا ويحرس حدود العراق سواء
كان من التدخل الايراني او التدخل التركي
او السوري او القطري او السعودي لماذا
الجيش منذ ان ان تسلمت الحكومه زمام
الامور في العراق دخل الجيش طيب هذا
السؤال هذا السؤال بعد بعد الفاصل هذا
السؤال مهم ساحاول بعد الفاصل للاستاذ
جاسم المسوي لكن استفسار بسيط جدا قبل قبل
الفاصل في هذا السياق انتم يعني العشائر
لماذا لا تقدم تعهدا واضحا بانها مستعده
لان تضيق الخناق على هؤلاء المسلحين في
مقابل انسحاب قوات الحكومه العراقيه من
الانبار سيدتي الفاضله من يريد ان يعطي
حسن النيه بالموضوع عليه اولا ان يسحب
الجيش الى سكناته العسكريه ثم تبدا
المفاوضات بهذا يعني المالك يسعى من خلال
هكذا اطروحات سياسيه وحلول سياسيه الى ان
يكون هنالك قتال عشائري ما بين ابناء
العشيره الواحده وابناء العشائر في محافظه
الانبار وبقيه المناطق الحل واضح وصريح
سينسحب الجيش الى السكنات العسكريه ثم
تتعهد العشائر بمقله بما يسمى ان وجد هكذا
هكذا مسميات الصوره واضحه وجليه انه ثوار
العشائر من اليوم الاول اذا سمحت لي عذر
المقاطعه ثوار العشائر هم الان الذين
يدافعون عن اعراضهم ومقدساتهم وممتلكاته
وقبل هذه الموضوع على العالم انس لا ينسى
وعلى حكومه المالكي ان لا تنسى او تتناسى
ان هنالك قبل هذه القضيه اام لاكثر من عام
ماذا قدمت حكومه المالكي من الحلول
المطاليب المشروعه التي قدمها المعتصمون
وما زال وما زال هنالك اعتصاما مفتوحا
وسلميه في بقيه المحافظات في كركوك وفي
سامراء وفي الموصل لماذا لا تحل بقيه
القضايا الموجوده في في المحافظات الاخرى
لماذا تركز القضيه على قضيه الانبار ودخول
الدوله الاسلاميه وقوات داعش وما يسمى
اليس هنالك الان الضيف الكريم الذي يتحدث
امامك اذا سمحت لي اليس هنالك انته وقتنا
في هذا الجزء الاول شكرا لك استاذ همام
حسين من مجلس ثوار
الانبار اذا تتركنا بعد هذا الجزء الاول
من البرنامج ويبقى معنا الاستاذ جاسم
المسوي من دوله القانون في هذا الجزء
الثاني من البرنامج ولكن بعد فاصل قصير
نناقش بعده طبيعه الدعم الامريكي لحكومه
نور المالكي في ضوء العمليه العسكريه
الجاريه في الانبار ابقوا معنا لا تذهبوا
بعيدا
عائدون
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا اهلا بكم من جديد الى هذه الحلقه
التي تناقش تصيد الحكومه العراقيه في
الانبار لعملياتها في الانبار والحديث عن
دعم امريكي للقوات الحكوميه في حربها ضد
تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه في العراق والشام
نرحب بضيفي من جديد ينضم الينا ضيف جديد
من
واشنطن السيد بنجامين فريدمان الخبير في
سياسات الامن والدفاع في معهدي كيتو اهلا
بك بك ابدا معك استاذ بنجمين فريدمان الان
والقوات الحكوميه العراقيه تخوض عمليات او
تصعد عملياتها العسكريه في
الانبار ياتي هذا التدريب تدريب امريكي
للقوات الخاصه العراقيه لماذا ياتي الان
تدريب القوات الخاصه الامريكيه في هذا
التوقيت في الواقع النقطه الاولى هي ان
القوات الامريكيه كانت تدرب القوات
العراقيه بشكل مستمر ربما باعداد صغيره
ولكن منذ مغادره القوات الامريكيه ثمت
هواجس في الولايات المتحده متصله بالاحداث
الاخيره في محافظه الانبار اي ربما
امكانيه انتشار وتعزيز الارهاب في هذه
المحافظه وان يتاثر او تتاثر الولايات
المتحده وينسحب ذلك ايضا على سوريا لهذا
الغرض اذا جاهذا التدريب لكن ضيفنا استاذ
منجمين قبل قليل السيد همام حسين وهو من
مجلس ثوار الانبار كان يقول ان مطالب
هؤلاء الناس في الانبار هي مطالب مشروعه
مطالب اجتماعيه مطالب اقتصاديه مطالب
سياسيه لماذا لم تقم حكومه نوري المالكي
على مدار عام كامل او اكثر بتنفيذ ولو جزء
بسيط من هذه
المطالب
لا اعرف
ما قد يكون حافزا بالنسبه لحكومه المالكي
لكن يبقى العراق مجتمعا منقسما وكثر في
الولايات المتحده يعتقدون ربما كيف يديرون
العراق ربما اعضاء مجلس شيوخنا انا لا
اعتقد ذلك ومن الواضح ان ما نراه في
الولايات المتحده اي على مستوى الكونجرس
وحتى الرئاسه الامريكيه رئاسه اوباما هي
عمليات مناهضه للارهاب وايضا احترام
لمعايير حقوق الانسان سوف يصحب ان نمزج
بين الامرين هنا افهم من كلامك استاذ
بنجمين فريدمان ان الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه تنظر الى ما يحدث في الانبار
على انه هذه العمليات انها حرب ضد الارهاب
وان مطالب الناس هناك مطالب غير مشروعه
برايك
لا لا اعتقد ان الولايات المتحده ككيان
عندها راي في هذا الصدد بهذا الاتجاه او
ذاك لكن ما تريده الولايات المتحده هو
هيكليه حكم عادله ومصفه في العراق حكومه
مركزيه في بغداد تنظر في مطالب الناس في
الانبار وغيرها من المحافظات وما تريده
الات المتحده في العراق هو لا شيء بكل
بساطه اي انسحاب وعدم مشاركه هو فصل في
السياسه الامريكيه طيب استاذ جاسم موسوي
هل طلبت الحكومه العراقيه هذا الدعم
الامريكي طبعا استلمت جزءا من الاسلحه
الامريكيه والان هناك تدريب للقوات الخاصه
العراقيه هل الحكومه العراقيه طلبت ذلك
وخصوصا انه كانت هناك انباء متواتره عن
سعي المالكي الى تحالفات في ظل العمليه
العسكريه المتواصله في الانبار ما مدى صحه
هذا
الكلام فقط انا ارجو الست خديجه لهذه
القناه المحترمه والتي انا احبها حقيقه ان
لا تخلط الاوراق بين مطالب يجب ان تنفذ من
خلال بوابه ديمقراطيه ومن خلال ممثليهم
وبين التنظيمات الارهابيه العراق يخوض حرب
نيابه عن العالم الحر هو يخوض ضد تنظيمات
ارهابيه هناك اتفاق بين العراق والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ضمن اطار الاستراتيجي
الذي عقد 2000 نهايه 2010 ان امريكا ملزمه
على دعم النظام السياسي الديمقراطي في
العراق وطالما ان العالم جميعه والعالم
الحر ينظر الى هذه المعركه فواجب على
الولايات المتحده ان تدرب القوات المسلحه
العراقيه وان تجهز القوات المسلحه
العراقيه وان النظام السياسي في العراق
قائم على قواعد هي قواعد يفتخر ويتشرب بها
العالم انها قواعد ديمقراطيه لا تمس حقوق
الانسان وفيها حفظ ولدينا دستور ولدينا
نظام ولا يمكن ان ان حقيقه ان ان يقال عن
السيد المالكي كما يقال عن بشار الاسد هذا
فرق كبير جداس معلش كلامك مقدر على العين
والراس ولكن هذه العمليه العسكريه منظمات
دوليه كثيره معنيه بحقوق الانسان تقول انه
هناك استخدام مفرط للقوه في الانبار كيف
ترد على هذه التقارير الدوليه والله وال
والله ي خديجه والله جزء من هذه المنظمات
التي تخرج تقاريرها يدفع لها المال صدقيني
انا ادعو م نيابه عن دوله القانون وانتم
بالذات الجزيره تعالوا وادخلوا الى اي
منطقه اذا كان هناك انتهاك لحقوق الانسان
بكل بساطه بكل بساطه الحكومه العراقيه لا
تترك وسائل الاعلام المستقله تدخل الى هذه
الاماكن وتصور وكل الكلام الذي تقوله عن
وجود مسلحين ومحاربه هؤلا المسلحين ل
فيديوهات او مقاطع فيديو واضحه صور خديجه
نعم تفضل ست خديجه هذه فبركات اولا
الاجواء جزء من سياده الد العراقيه عندما
نشعر ان هناك قنوات تدفع باتجاه التصعيد
الطائفي لا يمكن ان ان نسمح لها ان تطلق
سمومها نحن ندعو جميع القنوات وكل
القرارات التي تتخذ اتجاه القنوات تتخذ من
الهيئه والهيئه مستقله ومرتبطه بالبرلمان
العراقي وليس بحكومه المالكي ولذلك سيدتي
نحن لدينا المساحه الواسعه والكبيره ولكن
للاسف الشديد هناك من يحاول فبركه ونقل
درامه سوريا على الواقع العراقي نحن نواجه
الارهاب بحقيقته و وهناك لدينا نظام
ديمقراطي وصناديق اقتراع ومن يريد ان ياتي
الى الحكم نيابه عن المالكي فليات من خلال
صناديق الاقتراع هؤلاء يريدون ان يحملوا
السلاح بيد ويحاولون بطريقه تسمى
ديمقراطيه لاسقاط نظام الحكم ما الذي يجعل
امريكا تدعم الحكومه العراقيه ان لم تشعر
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان العراق
يواجه تنظيمات الارهابيه سينعكس ذلك على
جميع دول
المنطقه يجب ان تنتبهوا الى الى بنجمين
كيف تضمن الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ان
لا يوجه اي دعم عسكري لحكومه المالكي ضد
المدنيين في الانبار في الفلوجه
والفلو وم طريقه تسمح للحكومه الامريكيه
بان تضمن ان الحكومه في العراق لن تستخدم
الاسلحه ضد المدنيين ففي كل في حرب كان
ذلك على شكل حوادث او عمدا يقتل المدنيون
وهذا واضح حتى عندما نتحدث عن العراق ثمه
استخدام للعنف لا يميز في بعض الاحيان نعم
واحيانا يكون منتشرا احيانا ثمت اساءات
ايضا ضد المعتقلين والسجناء بالتالي من
غير المعقول بالنسبه لنا في الولايات
المتحده ان ندعم ونسل الحكومه الع
وتوقع منهم ايضا ان يتصرفوا كجنود نحن يجب
ان نختار اما ان نساعدهم واما ان لا
نساعدهم ولكن اذا ساعدناهم قد يقدمون على
امور لا تعجبنا احيانا بنجمين فريدمان
الخبير في سياسات الامن والدفاع في معهد
كيتو شكرا جزيلا لكنت معنا من واشنطن نشكر
ايضا ضيفنا من بغداد الاستاذ جاسم الموسوي
عضو اللجنه الاعلاميه لاتلاف دوله القانون
شكرا لك استاذ جاسم وشكرا لفريدمان بنجمين
فريدمان من واشنطن شكرا لكم انتم ايضا
مشاهدينا على متابعتكم لهذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في
قراءه جديده لما وراء خبر جديد لكم منا
اطيب المنى والى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء y